it's time for our favorite segment of
the week give it to me our wild money
moves of the week give it wpbd give it
to me give it to me pvp
so our wild money move of the week
features a little known man named
elon musk you ever heard of this guy i
think so he followed me on instagram
yeah did he cool yeah yeah me too i had
to block him
he kept asking me for like
ideas on rocket ships he's like hey can
i please be on sauce
dude i i can't do this just stop bro
just stop you're annoying at this point
so uh have you have you heard about what
the schedule that he does no okay so get
this this is why the elon who we talk
about quite often on pb podcast he's
number one richest person in the world
him or bezos or bernard or no he's in
the top three top five certainly yeah i
don't think he was even in the top 20
two years ago that's how
to the moon he is yeah um he's got the
most insane daily schedule you want to
hear it i'm afraid to but yes so you
know how they say making a budget for
your money is important well elon musk
says something ridiculous budgeting with
his time
he says time is money and i value my
time so this one guy he writes for
business insider who we talk about a lot
he says i tried elon musk's
productivity hack of breaking my entire
day into five minute time slots what
does that mean and here it goes what
does it mean yeah about to find out he
says it was annoyingly inflexible but i
got a lot more done let's talk about
what he's got so basically if you know
anything about elon musk he's very
meticulous with his time he splits his
days into five minute intervals we gotta
do this for five minutes do this for
five minutes do this for five minutes
cool cool cool cool he basically
prioritizes his
his um his workloads between his
companies that's how he does it between
tesla between uh boring companies the
boring company
between
spacex i mean you're you're on the ball
today yeah let me stop here well let's
see let me switch just just forget it
let's get out of here so basically um
[Music]
uh these guys are sp basically he's
basically spending his time moment by
moment basically figuring out the best
roi of his time time is money so um
so basically what he does he doesn't eat
breakfast boom gets right into the day
same thing okay he wolves down he
doesn't spend even five minutes on lunch
boom storm sounds his lunch and he
avoids phone calls no small talk this
guy's working working working working so
basically you want to work you want to
be successful just be a fast eater don't
spend your don't don't take an hour
lunch break they're done there okay wolf
down my stuff um
basically if you want to sp if you want
to make some money you want to build
wealth
cut out the fat literally and
figuratively that's what he does so this
guy stephen jones
steve jones he's the writer of this
article he basically put this
concept to test for a couple days he
says here's the realization quote
unquote it's almost impossible to get
anything done properly in five minutes
yeah other than maybe some emails or a
social media post five minutes keep in
mind
so basically rather than organizing his
days into five-minute slots he did this
he basically just jumbled them up
together okay and uh turned it into
basically a half hour time slots okay
six or twelve so so six or an hour time
slot and basically that's what he did is
boom boom boom boom boom but basically
limiting how long i had for a specific
task meant that i had to get it done
faster i got five minutes to do this i
gotta go what's up
knowing that i only had an hour to do it
really focused my mind cool
it also helped me cut out the
unnecessary distractions that cut that
can drain productivity like regularly
checking my inbox or scrolling through
social media i totally agree with that
um
five minute segments i mean this is
i i'm trying to like in my head right
now i'm applying it to my day to day i'm
gonna do some basic math real quick i i
don't know how i would do that i do i
mean
there are some things that just require
more time so what do i do after five
minutes do i move on to the next thing
and then come back to it after the
i don't know you know what i'm saying
like
so if there's 60 minutes in an hour and
everything's divided by five that's 12
things you're doing in an hour right and
if you're going to work but not not
fully like you're not i mean how well
could you be doing those 12 things
correct i don't know i mean that's why
i'm not multi-millionaire elon musk's
seven billionaires excuse me
get it right that's your first incorrect
statement of the day billionaire so if
you're doing 12 things in an hour and
you're working 12-hour days
right
you just did 144 things in a day well
hold on that's crazy you know uh yeah
lodiana has a good point here she goes
he probably has a huge team of people
doing all kinds of things for him elon
musk isn't doing his laundry done bingo
bingo you know let's let's give a shout
out to
pbd for a second patrick david this is
what he does exactly what elon musk does
exactly but rather it be in five-minute
intervals it's our intervals you know
how many times i've been having lunch
with pat we start at noon at one o'clock
he goes i gotta go i gotta go i'm like
dude we're like
he's like yeah yeah don't worry i gotta
i have a conference call at 115. i gotta
go yeah boom cuts it out of his life
have you ever noticed that everything
that we do here is like all right cool
from four to five we got this from five
to six we got this next day nine to ten
like very regimented life pat
as an example he has a lot of people
here working
for him with him
picking up the laundry picking up the
kids
doing whatever but the point is is he's
got a game plan for his time he's budget
his time accordingly so um
if you can budget your time better think
about more things that you can do
throughout the day so whether you're
elon musk and you're doing in five
minute intervals complete
wildness that you can't do whether
you're pbd and you do it you break down
the day by hour segments right you can
do 12 things in a day um that's that you
accomplish 12 things in a day that's six
days a week 12 things that's 72 things
done in a week extrapolate that times
365 that's
800 things that you're doing in a year
where the average person maybe gets 10
things done 50 things done 100 things
done they're getting thousands of things
done so rich people budget their time
that's what it is they allocate their
time wisely so if you're not doing this
you should think about it that's my
point what are your thoughts yeah i
think i mean obviously
the average joe has to give themselves
more than five minutes to do it because
you don't have those those but yeah i
mean you just have to stay disciplined
and organized and yeah stay on track
what are my tasks for the day and how
much i have to allocate time to this
because if you just say i have to do
this but you're not giving yourself a
limit then you can just do that one
thing until
whatever i have 20 minutes to do this i
have to do this and work and
that's what i can do you know it's not
something like for instance i i watch a
lot of our videos checking quality
control obviously an hour-long video i
can't do in five minutes of course 20
minutes but it's like no you can't do
that you can do it in 2x usb yeah i
watch everything in 2x speed i wouldn't
be offended people watch this in 2x
speed boom let me get that information
time for me to move on i gotta go out i
gotta go i gotta go listen
anyway it's good anyway we talk about
budgeting a lot
right um
budgeting your money we should also be
budgeting your time cool so respect on
that talk is money all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke